- You can't be scared of being something.
Being something in the beginning
is better than not being
anything ever at all.
You know, it's hard to get the match
and when you're just trading your time --
I could literally stay
in a Holiday Inn, I --
- I don't wanna fight.
- Fuck the middle.
But these fuckfaces don't listen.
The mindset that it is
your fault is the game.
And if you're capable, you'll be whatever
the fuck you want.
("Stay Calm" by @Awareness303)
Los Angeles, great day, heading first
to go see
the CEO of Activision.
Kind of our first meeting.
I know a lot about him through reputation.
Bobby's great a great one
and so excited about that conversation.
Later going to see media mogul,
manager extraordinaire,
entrepreneur extraordinaire,
Scooter Braun,
and I'm looking forward to that.
I've known Scooter a long time.
He's a diehard jazz fan, too,
and I love the whole Braun family
and his brother Adam is the founder
of Pencils of Promise,
a board that I'm extremely
passionate about.
And then a couple other secret meetings
and then just a whole lot of phone calls
and VaynerMedia stuff,
running the business
from my cell phone
and some pods.
I thought I was going to the office.
(laughs)
I guess we're not.
We're going to home.
Looking forward to it.
Should be a good meeting.
Will not be filming.
What can I talk about?
Let's, while I got a few seconds here
with you guys I'm just gonna look at some
tech headlines.
Google, da da da,
YouTube says creators will need 4,000
da da da da da,
cryptocurrency, massive decline,
da da da da da.
Nope, nothing interesting there.
- [Babbin] What about Vine Two?
You've been talking about that a lot.
- The Vine Too thing.
- What's interesting about the exclusion?
- I think it's gonna have a pop
from a lot of the Instagram, Snapchat
personalities for a second
and then if it's a good product,
it'll get going.
You know, it's hard to get the match.
So many of you struggle
with the match.
To get the match to start the fire
is very, very difficult.
And Vine Two will naturally have
that off the hype of
what it was and what it became.
And don't get it twisted,
Vine is the absolute seed
that accelerated the influencer movement
in the youth culture,
along with, you know, it was YouTube,
but YouTube was not mobile-centric, right?
It was desktop-centric.
Babbin.
And it was Vine
that was the precursor
to what we saw on Snapchat,
but more importantly,
long before Instagram
was reacting properly,
not copying, reacting,
enough with this copying shit.
(groans)
"We copied."
It's not, no, they reacted.
Long before Instagram reacted
to Snapchat's phenomenon,
it first reacted to Vine's phenomenon
and created one-minute video.
Instagram was pictures,
and a lot of the Vine celebrities
went to Instagram, where it was easier
to build even a bigger audience
at scale and different demos,
not just teenagers,
and so Vine has a very important
kind of like quick history
in kinda the game we're playing right now
and so Vine Two will be interesting
to just see what,
what it does, what the features are,
is it good, is it bad?
You know, MySpace rebooted
wasn't good enough
and that was it.
It had four hundredths of second, I think.
Vine has eight hundredths of second.
I think you'll see millions
of personalities, people
with Instagram followers,
Snapchat followers, and
a lot of my audience
that has learned you
buy beachfront property.
So I think a lot of you will jump
on Vine Two day one
and see if you can hit pay dirt
and virality and awareness
and so we'll see what's up.
Thanks, that was very good.
("Stay Calm" by @Awareness303)
- Basically the five days I take
with my wife every year,
where I'm not allowed to have
my cell phone, I have to put it
in the safe (laughter)
is when I get the most thinking,
as you can imagine,
especially by, like, six hours in,
I'm like "I'm gonna kill somebody"
and like, usually I'll just like sit
on the beach and like
draw out, like, priorities
and creating top of the funnel business
for L.A. is number one.
I'm really
mindful of like getting my energy
into here, like even I'm accomplishing
what I'm doing here right now.
- Less than an hour.
- Guys, please ping me if there's anything
I can answer for you, all right?
Have a great day.
("Stay Calm" by @Awareness303)
Text 'em, text 'em with me on it.
Tell 'em it's important to me.
Hi.
Couple of important meetings in L.A.
That went well, that's good.
- [Man] Heading to lunch
with Scooter Braun.
- Heading to lunch with
Scooter Braun, yes.
You know it's worth our effort
to produce a great,
super smart, clever video
where we got out of pocket
but we'd have to pay for it.
You know, James, I'll give you an example.
(man on phone talking indistinctly)
Okay then I'll go, I'll
call in the conference.
Phil, what I need from you
is to not project-manage
the open job descriptions of like
interviewing internally and externally.
What I think we need to figure out,
my biggest thing that I'd
like you to figure out
is like
how to get those candidates down
to the final two so that I can meet them
and have, or final three, and have
that conversation per job description.
Considering you're kind of negotiating
for like heavy discount or free,
I think we should be able to fill
all those positions by
the end of February.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- See you guys.
- Thank you.
- Thank you guys.
I'm heading out tomorrow morning.
Dude.
- Dude, I can't believe I see you
here in California.
How are you?
- How are you?
Good to see you.
- I've been following you so long.
- Thank you, man.
- Yeah, it's like
I sent you actually a pair of --
- I know exactly what this is.
I saw it.
- Oh, okay, so yeah, so I sent it
years ago when you're with the Jets
and Quicksilver.
- I remember, yeah.
- Okay, that's so awesome, man.
So with my company --
- Yes.
- I built that brand up,
selling in 65 countries,
doing it all online,
all because of Crush It,
and I feel like a pussy.
- Why?
- Because I had to go back a year ago
and get a regular job.
- So?
- Yes, it's just one of those things.
That's why I'm down here
in this monkey suit.
- I don't think that's right.
I think you're thinking about it wrong.
I think you're thinking
about it too short-term.
Like, you could start
up again in 24 months
and have something else
and, like, you know what I mean?
- You know what I've been doing?
I've been taking care of --
from all around the world,
so these are --
I haven't told them that I've gone back
to take another job, and I'm just,
I feel like we're in a time to where,
if I take care of the presence online,
still looks like a million
dollar brand online.
- Is that the right --?
- But yeah, man, I dove back into --
and it's like I was lucky.
- Dude!
Look, you've gotta sometimes take care
of whatever the hell you
have to take care of,
whether it's --
- Kids and --
- The bills, 100%.
But honestly, it's not about that.
I think here's how you think about it:
If you think about your nine to six
as like you're just sleeping.
- It's basically what I'm doing.
Like I'm just sleeping through this
and in the evenings,
but I'm getting phone calls today,
so the biggest struggle
that I'm having, then,
within it is so, and it was Phil Knight
that Shoe Dog millionaire, or Shoe Dog,
a show store, so he kept going back
to being an accountant, and so I was like,
"You know what?
"I gotta do that to feed this machine."
But what I underestimated
was the physical product.
Growing a brand just requires capital.
- Yeah.
- Beyond what I was
able to fund on my own.
- I get that.
- So yeah, so in any case --
- I don't, I think of
it as a minor step back,
three forward.
I'm running late for a meeting.
Real pleasure.
- Hey, thank you.
- Take care.
- Thank you, that was great, man.
Keep up the good work.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
You know, whether you fail,
whether not achieving
something is your fault
or not, having the mindset
that it is your fault
is the game.
You know, just sitting and I was writing,
this is for a lot of people right now
with managers, you know, and agents.
It's so easy to blame your manager
for not getting you gigs
or making you pop, except if you realize
you're the one who chose your manager
and you can fire them.
It's so easy to say you're not winning
'cause your assistant sucks
until you realize you're the one
who empowers it.
I could think my YouTube thumbnails suck,
but I also know that I'm the one
who empowers that decision
and, as you know, when we debated it,
I was like, "Okay, I'll
let you guys do it"
and even though I think I'm right,
like, it's just that.
Like, if you always think
that you're in charge,
like --
your husband's holding
you back, divorce his ass.
Or choose, you know, I
think we all make choices.
But my big thing is,
if you made the choice,
shut your fucking mouth.
Like people that like, well,
you've made the choice,
but then you also wanna just complain
about it all day, it's fucking loser shit.
You guys wouldn't care if I said,
"The thing for you to do is
"to go dance outside."
If you go outside, I have a funny feeling
if I told the three of you
"Go outside right now
and dance for an hour
"and your business will
do 48 million dollars
"in revenue this year"
you're gonna say yes.
Business people care about their business,
and so what I'm telling you is
that I'm thrilled to
figure out what you guys care about
from your business standpoint and deliver.
What I care about is
putting 25 to 50,000 dollars
into the pocket of one or two or three
of my players who know
that they could never
get that dollar amount any other place
than VaynerSports, got it?
What's the biggest impact or best thing
on your business?
Make sense?
Bye bye.
- What's up, brother?
- Good to see you.
- You made it out.
You made it out, this is the crew,
we're doing some filming.
- How you doing?
- A little behind the scenes.
- Good to see you, brother.
- You too.
- It's been great to see you lately.
- You remember Nick?
- I know Nick really well.
- Good to see you, man.
Where's D-Rock, he's not around, huh?
- No, we don't like him as much anymore.
Babbin's just better-looking.
(laughter)
You need coffee or anything, or water?
- No, I think I, I'll
take a water, actually.
- [Lewis] We have still for
you or you want some sparkling?
- [Gary] No, this is perfect.
- [Lewis] Gary Vaynerchuk in the house.
- Hey, brother.
- [Lewis] Good to see you, man.
- Great to see you.
Fun to be back.
- This is the third time
you'll be on this show.
- Second time here.
First time I was in my bedroom.
I remember because, I just
remember it, I don't know.
- [Lewis] So I think I've
talked to probably --
- I think the biggest reason I'm willing
to spit authentic is 'cause I don't think
so highly of myself,
meaning I'm not insecure.
It's just that, like, me
thinking Nick is not good
at something like business,
forget about photography
where, who gives a fuck?
Like, me saying your business stinks,
even with all my business things,
I still think is just one
fuckin' dude's opinion.
I understand it's a solid opinion.
I understand that it
comes with some heritage
and value, but it's still a --
too many great people who've won so much
in things have told me I'm not gonna win
and then I have won
that I know I'm the same
and so I think one of the reasons
I'm willing to spit is, like, my opinion's
still my opinion and, like, you know,
take it with a grain of salt.
I think what takes
everybody to the next level
is cutting out dumb shit.
I mean like no question
whether in your training,
in your business, in your friendships,
do you understand that if every person
in the world who's listening right now
started to weed off the friend
that is bringing the least value,
and I mean they're a bad influence,
they're bad mojo, they're bad.
Like, bad, I mean, they're just negative,
they're a negative person
so they're dragging you
down, they're selfish,
they have bad habits
like a drug addiction or something.
And you don't want to leave them,
I want to make sure people
when they hear me say this,
like, "Aww, you fuckin'
get rid of your friends?"
No, just if you audit your circle
of who you spend time with,
if you spent less time with something
that is broken and you added
one person that was incredibly valuable,
your life would be a lot better.
That's just real.
Such a pleasure, man.
- Nice to see you.
- How you doing?
- My uncle right there.
- Walter.
- Walter, such a pleasure.
Let's go.
I heard about like some guy making
a trade and his job was on the line
and so the kid didn't get to play.
So much.
But look at your situation.
Like, what I'm so fascinated by,
which is like, it's just
about getting the at-bat.
- Yeah.
- It's just about getting the at-bat
or like Jake Delhomme, who got to play
in the Superbowl as a quarterback.
If the World League didn't exist for that
like six years, well
then, he would've, like,
he'd be, you know.
- [Isaac] You see that again
with (talking indistinctly).
- What about Kurt Warner, right?
Kurt Warner was going
through grocery bags,
he was doing groceries
a year and a half --
- What about the receiver
in that Seahawks-Patriots
Superbowl that, had the Patriots not won,
he would've been the MVP
and he was working at FedEx
like six weeks earlier.
- [Isaac] That's crazy,
that's some crazy story.
- And that --
- [Isaac] On the other side, the corner
that made the interception
was an undrafted --
- Oh yeah.
- Yep.
- [Isaac] He wasn't even
supposed to be there,
but he ended up being
there, like, the savior
of the Superbowl.
- The same old thing, man.
- Jeff, nice to meet you.
- Jeff, such a pleasure, man.
How are things?
- These are my sad (mumbles).
- Are you ready for some savage shit?
- [Gary] I'm always ready for savage.
- About four years ago
I was touring the U.S.
On a tour bus with Zach Company.
Did 41 states, 175 different retailers,
learned all about like retail, etc.
- Distribution, all that?
- All that, found an artist, he wanted me
to rep him, I never managed anybody,
give a piece to Rob Kardashian to post
on Instagram, got 5,000 followers,
sold a piece a week later for 1,000 bucks.
Now, Drake --
- An artist.
- An artist, artist-artist.
- Artist-artist, not a rap artist.
- No, an artist.
Now Meghan Trainer, Snoop Dogg, Drake,
Jordan Parsons, D'Angelo Russell,
he was 20,000 dollar paintings,
500,000 dollars, probably, in (mumbles).
All the e-mails, 95% of the e-mails,
people couldn't afford the art,
so I'm like, "Wow, huge space
in the price point art."
I was like, "I don't
want to dilute the brand,
"but also I don't want
to limit our upsale."
So the idea, let's go 72 hours,
drop a limited-edition print.
We made 17 grand in three days.
I was like, "Wow, huge fuckin' space
"for price point art."
Where do you get art?
You get that bullshit art at Ikea,
you don't really know where to get art.
- The whole space --
- From an actual talent standpoint,
he's the best in the world,
it's not even fuckin' close.
From a speed standpoint, I'm talking 5X,
everybody else --
- Yeah, like the way we do shit.
- Exactly.
- The way I do --
- Yes.
- Like, be good and make a ton of it.
- And from a work ethic standpoint --
- Well, that's the only, by the way,
you don't have to say that part
because the other part
doesn't work without it.
You can't, the reason speed doesn't happen
is only two variables,
romance and work ethic.
- Well, we have problems.
We have no life, our family
is on the West Coast,
we're fuckin' out of our minds with work,
and I never see, from
an artist's standpoint,
like this motherfucker
pushed the pace of me,
which I've never had that
(mumbles), I love it.
- Okay.
- So we're 50-50 partners
and basically I -
- 50-50 partners in what?
- In Ikonic, so this what we did.
So, fucking around in 2016,
I was a big Instagram account
so I started bartering.
"You have half a million,
I have half a million,
"I'll post you twice, you post me once."
Zero marketing expense.
Black Friday last year, I made --
We're like, "Yo, we're gonna
make some fuckin' money
"doing this."
- Selling art.
- Selling art, but I'm gonna tell you
about the actual business details because
it's fuckin' crazy, but we
keep watching your shit,
which we started probably
January of last year,
and you keep saying
Facebook, Facebook, Facebook.
Finally, we were like, "Fuck."
- Fuck, if he's so good
and he keeps saying it,
let's fuckin' see!
- Ready for that shit, though?
February 27th we go from
Squarespace, Shopify,
we invest in Facebook, month --
Month one, month one, month one!
- I mean, I try to tell people, like --
- Dude, it gets better.
- It gets so much better.
- Of course it gets
better when you make --
month one, shit gets better.
- It's getting so good
and we're just starting.
- Brother,
I mean I don't know how,
you're busy,
you know, look, like I don't know how
to explain it more than the way
I'm explaining it, like, it's much,
like I'm about to become
one of the hundred
most famous people in this country
on this same thesis.
- Right, it's the same, exact.
- You know what's crazy?
No one's listening, either.
We try and tell people?
No one listens.
- I know.
- No one listens.
- By the way, do you know why I give away
all my advice for free?
I realize nobody listens. (laughs)
Like I give away such good advice,
but these fuckfaces don't listen,
so that means I can still get mine,
and people like you are like,
do you know how much you guys love me?
- Love you.
I think that we have a lot of cheat codes
that no one knows about.
- Yeah, 'cause you're in the trenches.
- Yeah, 'cause we're so fuckin' deep.
- The only people that have cheat codes
are the people that actually are, like,
it's kind of like if we're
using video game terms,
you can't know the cheat
code unless you're actually
burning the bush and
realize the key was behind
the fuckin' bush.
Like, I was great at
Zelda, 'cause all I did
was, like, it was more fun to me to find
which rock to push than
beat the fuckin' game.
I'm only about cheat codes.
Like, honestly, I will
not make the most money
because I enjoy too much
about the cheat code.
- Yeah, I just love fuckin' --
- Some people love to make money.
I don't.
I like to break shit, and
the only way you break shit
is you're doing shit that doesn't seem
to make any sense in the short term
until you're like "Why did this rock move?
"Oh shit, coins!"
You know?
I'm waiting for my buddy
Rohan Oza to come in.
I think he should be here any minute.
There he is, I see him walking in.
Came here for his 40th birthday years ago.
We've literally been missing,
two planes in the night.
I haven't seen him in years, actually,
but communicate with
him, he's crushing it.
Incredible brand guy,
Vitamin Water, Buy Five,
just like unlimited, he's like a beast,
crushes it on Shark Tank
and I'm just fond of him.
Look forward to choppin' it up with him.
How long ago was that?
- Dude, like a hundred years ago.
- What that your 40th?
This is Babbin.
- [Babbin] How's it going?
- [Rohan] How're you doing, buddy?
Good to see you.
- [Gary] Was that your 40th?
- [Rohan] Yeah, 40th.
- [Gary] I'm fine, and
what are you now, 46?
Well, you haven't aged.
- [Rohan] I try not to, man.
- You figured it out.
- I remember the first lunch we had.
- Me too.
- Down in Gramercy.
- Mm-hmm.
- We were both like "All
right, we're gonna do
"some things here and
we're gonna do some things
"together, by the way."
- The good news is, we have time,
but it's really great to, like,
it just all, you know it's funny,
I said to somebody today, I'm like,
"You already know who the
39 players are gonna be."
(Rohan laughs)
It's actually, so probably the reason
I've been having a lot of energy
to like keep reaching out to you
and make this happen, glad we did it,
is I was literally walking on the beach
and I'm like, "You know,
I actually know already
"who's gonna win and who do I like."
- Because people can win, but
you don't wanna be around.
- Correct.
- That's very true, that's correct.
- Correct, and I'm like,
"I have to make a better
"commitment because we're
all the same character."
The same people that are gonna win
are the same character,
which is, literally,
we haven't seen each
other in like four years,
maybe, and it feels like
I saw you yesterday.
And I feel like we've been talking.
- Yes, I 100% agree.
- So I, I said to myself, you know what?
That's exactly right, I feel the same way
about them as they do,
it's complete serendipity
if you're seeing somebody,
but I'm gonna do a little
bit of a better job
in trying to find more time
with people that I wanna see.
That's it.
Simple as that.
- I'm gonna do that same.
I used the word, when I
did my New Year's post,
get balanced.
It doesn't mean we slow down.
It just means you maybe do
less of the small stuff.
- That's it.
- And more of the bigger stuff, right?
- That's right.
- It's just the balance.
- No no, that's exactly right.
- 'Cause, like, you can
pack, I mean you do pack
your day, but, you could just --
- I pack my day, but literally 31 kids
are gonna leave comments
on this YouTube vlog
about how cool they are, they're pumped
that I introduced, they looked into you
and like, oh my god, you're such a boss.
And I'm gonna meet with six of them,
which is amazing.
- Yeah, I gotta learn
from you in this stuff.
- But I might need to meet two of them
and be able to do like three,
like have this meeting.
Literally this meeting
is happening right now.
If it wasn't, I'd be
meeting some influencer
on Instagram and some, you know,
up and coming hip hop artist.
Which is great, or a
client or trying to buy Uno
from Mattel, or whatever
the fuck I'm doing,
but there's, I'm trying
to, I've made a mental list
of like 30, 40 guys and girls,
and I'm like, "I'm gonna triple down
"on those relationships."
- Smart.
- Because they're valuable.
- Scooter's one of them
as well, obviously.
- Of course.
- Smart guy, great guy.
- Scooter's my homey, homey, homey,
and I don't think I've
seen him in 18 months.
Because again, I realize, Ashton too,
which I didn't pull off on this trip
'cause he had to flight to San Francisco,
but like, I already know
who the fuckin' people are.
I know who they are.
- It's funny, like Ashton,
who's unbelievable,
asked me, 'cause we did
dumb stuff together.
- Yes.
- People don't understand
how smart that guy is.
- I know, well, that's 'cause
he was a real celebrity
before he got smart.
- Right.
And by the way, the stuff
he was a celebrity on,
which was like, the '70s
show, even The Ranch,
what he's doing now --
- Hey Dude, Where's My Car? (laughs)
- Yeah.
- But the public perception was so goofy,
but he's so smart.
- When I sit down and have, like --
- The best.
- I'm lost in tech conversations with him.
- 'Cause he's operating at
a higher level than I am.
- The best, the best.
- Then you've got grocery
where, some groceries
try and match like an --
- Yep, yep, yep.
- And they work off a smaller margin,
and others realize they're working off
a high margin, so they have higher pricing
and they do promos to try and --
- That's right.
- Costco says "You ship direct to me,
"it's a bulk item, you
don't sell individuals."
Everyone's got their place.
It's like the jungle, right?
Lions can coexist, even
though they're the strongest,
lions can coexist with gazelle,
'cause the gazelles just --
- I totally understand.
- Okay.
What happens today if
you introduced a T. Rex
into the jungle?
- Well, that's what happened.
- Exactly, so the T. Rex
is eating everything.
- The greatest part of that is why
the direct-to-consumer business is gonna
be so important.
- Yeah, but what Amazon is doing,
the problem is, if they had to operate
their business on a profitable basis
like everybody else, it'd be a fair game.
- That's fine.
- But they're making so much money
in the left hand it doesn't matter
what they're doing in the right hand
and then they're saying, well,
"We're gonna sell singles
or whatever it is,
"but if you're pricing
at Costco is this" --
- My friend, loss leaders have existed
for a long time.
They just have to most
macro fuckin' loss leader.
- [Rohan] He lives in L.A.?
- I don't know, I don't know.
But he's like legitimately --
- [Rohan] Do you have a place out here?
- No.
- [Rohan] Where do you stay?
- SLS.
- [Rohan] Really?
- Yeah.
Why, where do you want me to stay?
- Get a place out here.
- I thinking about, so nice to meet you.
Thank you for the hospitality.
I'll talk to you soon, brother.
- [Rohan] SLS doesn't feel relaxing to me.
- I mean I sleep, I could literally stay
in a Holiday Inn.
I like walk in, go to sleep, and leave.
(laughter)
That's literally where I'm at.
Thanks, brother.
I'll talk to you later.
- [Rohan] Good seeing you.
- Good to see you, Rohan.
- [Babbin] How do you think our,
like you guys were talking about Ashton
at the beginning, how he
went from like this goofy
thing to being seen as like
a whole different monster.
- Yep.
- [Babbin] Do you think,
like, it's just natural
that you'll be pigeonholed
as like one thing?
How do you --
- Well, at that scare, at that scale.
- [Babbin] How do you
force the system to, like,
see you as other stuff?
That's like my personal demons,
I'm always scared of, like,
being seen as one thing
and not being able to do other stuff.
- If you are it, you are it.
If Mark Wahlberg is a movie star,
if Dwayne Johnson is a movie star,
then they go from being The Rock
and from being Marky Mark.
If I am a entrepreneurial mogul,
I won't be the wine guy.
That's all that people call me.
2009, 10, 11, 12, all I ever heard was
"Oh, the wine guy?"
You can't be scared of being something.
Being something in the beginning
is better than not being
anything ever at all,
and if you're capable, you'll
be whatever the fuck you want.